what was your first thing you did to
make money um first thing was selling
garbage bags door to door I wanted some
basketball shoes and my dad basically
said those shoes work you know that you
have on your feet and when you have a
job you can get whatever you want and
um one of his poker buddies set me up to
sell garbage bags door-to-door to so I
can get some basketball shoes yeah so
what are you teaching your kids about
going to college
um well my kids are four seven to ten so
but I mean you're thinking about this
what I try to teach them is that you
know you've got to a learn how to learn
to me the most important part of college
is you know are you learning how to
learn because learning is a lifetime
achievement you know something you've
got to continuously do and one of the
things that I'm trying to create varied
interests for them because I don't care
what they major in in college as long as
they learn and I want them to to start
now being excited about learning